Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Ich äh habe da übrigens noch ein paar Setektoren äh hinterlegt, da könntest du mir ja dann zu gegebener Zeit äh vielleicht nochmal die passenden Daten dazu rüberschieben.
Ich muss das erste Mal hier noch von unserer G zehn Kommission genehmigen lassen.
Logbuch, Netzpolitik, die eins steht vorne, die zweiundvierzig steht hinten die Sendung, auf die ihr wahrscheinlich schon lange gewartet habt. Ähm
Mal schauen, ob wir das auch entsprechend füllen können. Aber jenseits äh der Zahlen äh Mystic ähm,
müssen wir das euch leider wahrscheinlich enttäuschen. Wir warten einfach nur ein weiteres Mal durch den Moras dieser Enttäuschung.
Ich sehe gerade, hier gibt's äh schon, also es gibt Kommentare, die sich äh äh beschweren.
Über die über die mangelnde Erscheinungsfrequenz des Lokbuches,
Ähm ja ähm einerseits, ne, wir sind ja hier ihr bezahlt ja nicht genug, als dass wir davon leben könnten, also sind wir jetzt zu zu Tage, zu Tagelöhnertätigkeit gezwungen.
Genau. Frohen.
Es waren, also letzte Woche lag es auch daran, dass die Themenlage noch nicht so ausreichend war, so dass wir gedacht haben, ach, machen wir einen Tag später und dann wurde es aber eine Woche später, so äh passiert es manchmal.
So sieht's aus. Ja äh das heißt nicht, dass es äh nicht auch noch äh sonstiges äh Feedback gegeben hat.
Ja, es gab zwei äh zwei interessante Kommentare, was nicht so heißen soll, dass die anderen uninteressant war, aber diese zwei haben wir ausgewählt
Eine Frage kam von oder die Ergänzung kam von Martin Schröder, denn wir hatten uns ja in der letzten Woche gewundert, wieso denn ausgerechnet Petra Pau
in der vorletzten Woche gewundert warum denn ausgerechnet Petra Pau die Öffentlichkeit darüber in Kenntnis setzt, dass Cyber Cyber im Bundestag ist.
Und äh die Auflösung lautet Petra Pau ist Vizepräsidentin des Deutschen Bundestags und leitet die IT Kommission des Ältestenrates des Bundestages, dürfte also so etwas wie die
CIO des Bundestags sein. Chief äh Information Officer.
Sowas gibt's aber nicht wirklich offiziell oder doch.
Nein, nein, nein. Und wenn, dann ist das also äh es der soweit ich das Recht in Erinnerung habe, ist der größere Teil der Bundestags-IT an. Ähm Dienstleister.
Ähm.
Oder die Pflege der Bundestags hier an Dienstleister outgesourct und ähm da wird dann irgendwo eine aber irgendjemand wird ja die Entscheidung treffen, ne? Und da wird sie halt irgendwie dran beteiligt sein.
Hm, outgesourct ist das interessant. Also nicht das mit groß überraschen würde, aber naja.
Ja, die haben halt, Alter, was heißt Outresos? Ja, die haben halt irgendwie eine, also ich,
kenne mehrere Leute, die ja halt schon mal bei eben Zulieferern des Bundestages gearbeitet haben und dann da irgendwie so von
Mailserver konfigurieren über Drucker installieren und so. Das muss ja auch alles gemacht werden.
Ja, das stimmt allerdings. Frage mich bloß halt immer, ob das nicht äh ganz angemessen ist, gerade in so äh Krisensituationen, wie gerade darauf werden wir ja gleich nochmal zu sprechen kommen, äh dann auch eine gewisse eigene Kompetenz aufgebaut zu haben. Über die Zeit.
Ja, also kommen wir gleich nochmal zu. Äh es ist immer so ein hin und her, ne. Es ist so die Frage. Ich meine.
Du kannst natürlich sagen, okay, wir machen das alles selbst, dann machst du aber auch alle Fehler selbst und ähm.
Externen Dienstleister kannst du halt da
darauf hoffen, dass der Star schon mehr Erfahrung ist als du vielleicht oder mehr Kompetenz vorhanden ist, als du vielleicht dir mit äh uninformierten Vorstellungsgesprächen in deinen Laden einkaufen kannst, ne?
Na ja. Dann gab's eine, einen eine Idee von Miko.
Der sagte, ob man denn nicht ähm die.
Veränderungen, also quasi Netzneutralitätsverletzungen oder Datenstrom, Veränderungen.
Von denen Tim berichtet hatte, also dieses Verändern der Bilder, die man abruft, ähm als strafbar deklariere und könnte nach Paragraph dreihundertdrei B Computer Sabotage,
der lautet, wer eine Datenverarbeitung, die für einen anderen von wesentlicher Bedeutung ist, dadurch erheblich stört, dass er eine Tat nach Paragraph dreihundertdrei,
Absatz eins begeht, Daten in der Absicht, einem anderen Nachteil zuzufügen, eingibt oder übermittelt oder eine Datenverarbeitungsanlage oder einen Datenträger zerstört, beschädigt Unbrauchbar macht, beseitigt oder verändert
wird mit Freiheitsstrafe bis zu zwei Jahren oder mit Geldstrafe bestraft. Klingt natürlich erstmal so, dass man sagen könnte, so okay, das äh,
könnte man eventuell unter diesen Paragraphen fassen. Ähm dazu gibt es eine Antwort von Ulf Buhrmeier,
Auf die Gefahr hin jetzt wieder Oberlehrer rüberzukommen, klassisches Missverständnis. Die Grundrechte wenden sich zunächst mal nur an den Staat
Die Provider sind ja im Prinzip nicht gebunden, es sei denn, der Staat setzt das Grundrecht in einfaches Recht.
Grundrecht bisher kaum getan hat oder legt zum Beispiel Verträge aus. Das ist alles völlig kompliziert, wer mit Google die Drittwirkung von Grundrechten.
Will Google mal die Drittwirkung von Grundrechen und eignet sich jedenfalls nicht für einen Schnellschuss la Provider verletzten Grundrechte durch Netzneuritätsverstoß.
Jetzt bringst du glaube ich.
War allerdings jetzt die Antwort zu einer anderen Frage, die ich vorgelesen habe.
Genau, das äh jetzt.
Zwei Sachen äh durcheinander. Das das was äh worauf sie
Ulf äh drauf bezieht, das war halt ähm meine grundsätzliche Überlegung, inwiefern denn äh die Grundrechte herangezogen werden können, um äh dieses Vergehen der Unternehmen, also das, was wir als Vergehen verstehen zumindest, ähm zu.
Ähm maßregeln und da ist halt der Hinweis von Ulf eben einfach in die Richtung Grundrechte sind erstmal nur für den Staat, nicht für Unternehmen
der Hinweis von mikro wiederum geht aber eine andere Richtung, nämlich ob der nicht grundsätzlich äh auch das existierende Strafgesetzbuch im Sinne von
hier werden Daten verändert herangezogen werden kann. Da haben wir jetzt noch keine passende Antwort von irgendeinem Juristen, der uns dann erklärt, dass wir doch alle blöd sind. Ähm
Ich finde das ganz interessant, weil wenn man in diesem Strafgesetzbuch mal hinterherklickt so, dann hat man dann eben hier auch so Paragraph zwei null ähm, warte mal, was war das jetzt, dreihundertdrei,
B wurde ja hier zitiert, ne? Das verweist dann auf dreihundertdrei A, das ist dann der Paragraph zur Datenveränderung, ja. Wer rechtswidrig Daten löscht, unterdrückt unbrauchbar macht oder verändert, ja?
Wird mit Freiheitsstrafe bezahlt und.
Zeit.
Genauer, das wird das wird alles mit Freiheitsstrafe bezahlt. Ähm.
Ähm jetzt gucke ich ganz durcheinander.
Es ist ja schon so, dass sich in der Gesetzgebung der letzten Jahre, ne, mit dieser ganzen Hacker-Paranoia und so weiter, da kommen dann ne, so Hacker mit Maske, äh sitzt seinem Kinderzimmer
und macht halt irgendwie alles kaputt. Und jetzt haben wir irgendwie so tolle,
Gesetze, die halt sagen, naja, wenn da einer kommt und hier irgendwie meine Daten verändert, dann ist das halt alles erstmal potenziell böse und gemein. Da kann man ja auch durchaus sagen, ja klar, da gibt's auch viele Fälle, wo das zutrifft. Und warum das nicht ganze auch erweitern
auf das Verändern meiner Datenströme. Wenn du meine Webseite klickst, dann ist das ja, das könnte man sagen
das in Anspruch nehmen eines Angebots im Zweifelsfall auch eines kommerziellen Angebots, das interessiert ja die Politik immer besonders gerne. Ja, und wenn ich da jetzt einfach reingehe und irgendwas ersetze, äh dann ist das einfach ja, potenziell.
Ich sage mal, mindestens erstmal schon mal bedenklich. Ja, vielleicht greift dieses Gesetz, vielleicht greift es nicht, aber es ist ja so,
diese Eingriffe finden ja statt und es finden Eingriffe statt im Sinne von, na ja, ich rechne dir mal die Bilder runter, damit ich weniger Daten übertragen muss, ja?
Was ja dann auch schon eine Einschränkung ist, weil ich gebe mir unter Umständen viel Mühe, hochauflösende Bilder zu liefern für dein äh äh modernes Endgerät. Und dann kommt da halt irgend so ein bekloppter Provider dazwischen, meint so, ah ja, hier viel zu viele Daten und so weiter. Das will ich jetzt nicht alles übertragen. Ich mache das mal hässlich und scheiße.
Ja, wo dann vielleicht Details fehlen, keine Ahnung, et cetera, weiß man ja nicht, ne? Da wird halt irgendwas angefasst und modifiziert, ohne dass ich darüber Kenntnis und Kontrolle habe.
Und äh im Falle von Werbung und das ist ja dieser andere Trend, ne, so nach dem Motto, na ja, da ist jetzt die Werbung äh drin, die wir uns nicht
passt, da packen wir mal eine andere rein. Das halte ich dann schon eben auch für sehr kriminell, weil das Anbieten der Werbung ist ja äh unter Umständen auch eine Dienstleistung, für die ich,
ähm bezahlen, also wo ich nicht nur Geld mit äh verdiene potenziell, sondern wo ich ja auch einen Vertrag habe, dass ich
vielleicht gezwungen bin, das einzublenden und wenn ich das halt nicht tue, in dem Fall
dann äh fügt mir jemand anderes einen Schaden zu, weil ich meinen Vertrag nicht einhalte. Also so in diese Richtung äh fände ich das mal ganz interessant, dass zu debattieren und auch da würde ich mich freuen, wenn sich ein paar äh Gesetzeskundige, die dann wieder auf uns einschlagen
dürfen mal zu Wort melden.
Ja starker Einstieg von von uns. Falsche Antwort zur richtigen Frage. Ähm ich ich,
ich wage trotzdem eine Vermutung, um äh um den Karren jetzt auch wirklich ganz in den in den äh in den Moras zu treten. Ich wage die Vermutung, dass sich das alles durch äh
kleine äh Buchstaben in den AGBs äh erklären lässt und sicherlich nur ein großes Missverständnis ist.
Genau.
So, dann hatten wir in der letzten Woche ähm.
Den Kabinettsbeschluss, der Vorratsdatenspeicherung, also Kabinett ist äh Kanzler und Minister.
Und Ministerinnen, Kanzlerin.
Kanzlerin, Minister und Ministerinnen. Ähm,
setzen sich zusammen und sagen, das ist jetzt der äh Gesetzesentwurf, welchen wir an das Parlament herunterreichen, äh wo er dann mit unserer robusten Mehrheit ähm doch bitte von unseren,
äh gewählten Wählern beschlossen werden möge.
Und ähm der Zeitplan, den sie sich dafür gegeben haben, sieht vor, dass er schon so in
also fünf Wochen danach, also jetzt inzwischen in vier Wochen, dann
wirklich durchs Parlament äh gehen soll. Ähm eine Anhörung sehen sie dabei jetzt nicht großartig vor. Da haben also schon die haben auch Verbände sich jetzt irgendwie beschwert und gesagt, hey, kannst ja nicht einfach so was machen, ohne hier eine
Sachverständigenanhörungen zu machen. In der SPD äh regt sich der Widerstand, aber ja, was soll's?
Also in der die SPD äh lästern verlauten etwa einhundert Parteigliederungen wie Landesverbände, Ortsverbände und Unterbezirke äh werden.
Im Vorfeld des Partei äh oder haben im Vorfeld des Parteikonvents Anträge gegen die Vorratsdatenspeicherung gestellt. Der Parteikonvent ist am zwanzigsten Juni
kurz davor findet die erste Lesung im Parlament statt. Das heißt, da da ist schon nochmal so ein
Parteikonvent der SPD, wo sie denn irgendwas beschließen könnten, was aber dann eigentlich wieder ohne jegliche also ohne sinnvolle ähm Bindung,
äh wäre. Und wenn man sich jetzt die Sitzverteilung im deutschen Bundestag anschaut, ähm,
dann machen, irgendwann mal kurz, ich habe ja hier sogar einen Link vorbereitet. Ähm kannst du auch gerne mal klicken. Da siehst du,
Die SPD hat hundertdreiundneunzig Sitze und die CDU CSU dreihundertelf. Das ergibt für die CDU CSU und SPD eine äh Mehrheit von irgendwie um die achtzig Prozent.
Das heißt, selbst wenn jetzt einhundert,
Sozialdemokraten ähm überzeugt werden könnten, quasi erneut,
umzukippen, ja? Und diesmal irgendwie halt ihre Parteizeit verraten. Wäre ja auch mal eine Option, ne? Die Parteilinie zu verraten, dann dann würde es immer noch nicht ausreichen.
Ähm um diesen äh oder um diesen Gesetzesentwurf äh irgendwie daran zu hindern, Gesetz zu werden.
Also wir haben da im Moment äh dieses sehr schöne.
Da kann man wirklich von dem schönen Beispiel äh durchregieren sprechen, denn der die Mehrheit der ähm der Bundesregierung,
Im Parlament ist äh immens. Da wackelt nichts mehr. Die können machen, was sie wollen und tun das ja auch.
Ja, muss man halt mal dran erinnern, nicht? Ich meine, als sie sich dieser Bundestag gefunden hat, hätte die CDU im Prinzip auch locker mit den Grünen zusammen gehen können, von den Zahlen her, ne, weil
CDU hat irgendwie dreihundertelf, also schon fast die absolute Mehrheit. Ja, da da hat jetzt nicht mehr äh viel gefehlt, also ihnen fehlten einfach nur wenige Sitze.
Und die kann halt jeder äh da ausfüllen. Das heißt, man müsste im Prinzip die SPD schon so komplett zum äh Kippen bringen. Oder was man eigentlich halt tun müsste, ist,
man muss eben der SPD nachhaltig das Gefühl äh vermitteln, was ich meiner Meinung nach dann halt auch einstellen wird. Das äh ja, danach einfach mal ein noch ähm in
einzelnen Bereichen vorhandener Glaube an die SPD, dann doch so nachhaltigen Schaden erfährt, dann doch wieder,
kümmern sich wahrscheinlich nicht groß drum.
Ich glaube zwei Anmerkungen. Erstens, die Frage ist nicht, ob die CDU mit den Grünen äh hätte koalieren können. Die Frage ist, dass die scheiß SPD sich einfach mal zusammenreißt und mit den Linken äh sich zu einer äh Opposition hätte zusammenschließen müssen
ja? Aber die SPD ist ja also die ähm die SPD schließt ja immer äh die die
die die Zusammenarbeit mit der Linken aus, weil das sind ja die Bösen, das sind ja die Abtrünnigen, das sind ja die, die die uns verraten haben, ja. So äh ist ja die Vorstellung in der SPD,
ähm.
Der äh der andere Punkt ist, ich glaube dieses,
dieses Gefühl, dass die SPD keinen Rückhalt mehr hat, das äh hat die SPD ja inzwischen auch ereilt, ja, wenn sie irgendwie.
Wenn sie sich ihre Wahlergebnisse mal anschauen. Ähm ich fürchte, dass sie nur genau den falschen Schluss daraus ziehen. Ja, also ich glaube, dass die SPD sich inzwischen echt wahrscheinlich gedacht hat, na ja, ähm.
Wir werden, also wir werden nicht mehr äh Volkspartei sein, so. Ähm,
Wir werden auch nicht mehr die Mehrheit oder die größte, die größte äh Fraktion im Bundestag sein. Dann wollen wir wenigstens dafür sorgen, dass wir irgendwie noch an der Regierung beteiligt sind.
Und äh zusehen, dass wir der der
präferierte Juniorpartner der CDU CSU werden. Also genau aus dieser Sorge weitere Stimmen zu verlieren, handelt die SPD wahrscheinlich gerade genauso, wie sie's tut. Also absolut ähm absolut äh verkorkste Situation. Am besten wär's, wenn wir es schaffen, die irgendwie zuzumachen.
Selbst Selbstmord aus äh Angst vor dem Tod.
Ja
Na ja es ist ein äh Drama, aber ich meine mit den linken können sie natürlich äh nicht zusammen gehen, weil dann dann kommt ja Sozialismus und wie wir wissen, ist das ja überhaupt das Schlimmste, was passieren kann.
Das wäre schlimm, wenn wir auf einmal hier sowas wie Chancengleichheit oder sowas herstellen würden. Ja, das können wir nicht machen.
Ja, nee, also das äh Denker, die Krankenwagen. Da kommen wir noch zu. Schlimm schlimm.
Was was soll man da dazu noch sagen? Also ich meine es
du hast das jetzt gerade so ein bisschen vorbei äh prasseln lassen, aber diese Verbände, die sich da zu Wort gemeldet haben, das ist ja eine ganze zahlreiche äh Liste, die wenn ich das richtig sehe, so ein bisschen unter der Führung der Eco.
Oder ich weiß nicht, ob das eine Führung ist. Äh wir haben jetzt hier die Pressemitteilung von denen verlinkt. Vielleicht haben die auch alle rausgehauen. Es gab da auf jeden Fall so einen
äh Branchenaktivität, Breko, äh VATM, Anga, alles so Gruppen, von denen man seltener was hört, also es vergibt einen Bundesverband Breitbandkommunikation, ja, wusste ich auch noch nicht.
Ah, doch, den kenne ich. Die laden immer zu irgendwie so einer Breitbandmesse ein.
Mhm, das ist schön.
VATM, das sind die äh die die kümmern sich um Mehrwertdienste. Das sind, glaube ich, so, die haben ihren, die müssen.
Nullhundertneunzig. Drei, drei, eins, vier, vier, eins.
Ja genau, das sind eher die Jungs, glaube ich. Kabelbranche, Initiative Europäischer Netzbetreiber.
Null null neunhundert Nummer äh.
Also ich habe ja noch einige Ideen zum Monetarisierung des Logbuchs. Wir machen ja demnächst Paywall und dann äh.
Weißt du?
Okay, da stehen wir mal in den Epilog.
Äh ähm.
Also, ich will sagen, es gibt.
Widerstand aus der äh Businesswelt, klar, ich meine gerade die äh Provider äh Gruppen und so weiter, die haben jetzt hier noch eine ganze Menge mehr zu verlieren,
Nicht nur so, dass sie sich jetzt äh irgendwie rechtlich angegriffen fühlen, sondern es hat ja auch was wieder mit der Frage zu tun, wer zahlt das Ganze,
ich weiß gar nicht, ob in dem aktuellen Entwurf dazu irgendwelche nennenswerten ähm Informationen schon zu finden sind.
Wie ich mich richtig erinnere, als wir das erste Mal das diskutiert haben, als das wieder neu aufkam, gab's schon so den Hinweis, so ja, da müssen wir dann
noch ein bisschen Geld drauf werfen und äh passt schon irgendwie. Frage ist, ob sich halt diese Branchenverbände letzten Endes damit abspeisen lassen oder ob die hier in der Lage sind, noch nennenswerteren Widerstand zu entwickeln.
Also ohne da jetzt aktiv Anbieter zu bewerben zu wollen, denke ich, ist aber jetzt durchaus mal die Zeit für die Übergangsphase, bis das dann hoffentlich in Karlsruhe wieder alles kassiert wird,
sich schon mal ähm seine ähm Gewohnheiten umzubauen und möglichst.
Viel durch äh das Tornetzwerk oder durch.
Ähm internationale VPN-Anbieter äh zu ruten und natürlich immer schön darauf achten, dass man den Traffic, den man da durchwirft, auch äh entsprechend verschlüsselt und so weiter, um sich eben der Erfassung
Durch die Vorratsdatenspeicherung möglichst zu entziehen. Telefonieren auch nicht mehr, klar, ne, Handy aus,
wird sonst äh wird ja alles protokolliert. Aber so langsam muss man sich da äh
glaube ich, für den Impact Bracen. Auch wenn jetzt die ganzen ähm Verbände auf, wo sie natürlich recht haben, sagen, aufgrund der wirtschaftlichen und gesellschaftspolitischen Tragweite, einer anlasslosen Datenspeicherung ist ein bedachtes und wohlüberlegtes
gesetzgeberisches Vorgehen bei der Schaffung neuer Regelungen und Vorgaben zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung besonders wichtig. Ähm
sagen, es ist weder sinnvoll noch angemessen, eine solche Maßnahme im Alltempo zu verabschieden. Haben sie natürlich Recht.
Merket euch, liebe Kinder, wie das damals kam.
Ciao. Höhlenbau einleiten.
Und Spaten, ne? Also Spaten, eigene Leitungen wieder vergraben und Freifunknetze und Hasse alles nicht gesehen. Wir müssen jetzt hier echt mal,
in den digitalen Untergrund gehen, weil,
im Endeffekt, ne, muss man ja auch mal sagen, so diese Infrastruktur, der die Vorratsdatenspeicherung jetzt unterliegt, ne, die ist ja jetzt auch nicht irgendwie besonders äh weltbewegend. Also diese Paar Mbit, äh ich um dich jetzt nochmal kurz zu triggern über den den äh,
Es folgt ein Bandbreiten, ähm da kann man doch auch drauf scheißen, auf die PMBIT, oder? Das können wir, das kriegen wir doch selber besser hin.
Oh Mann, ey. Megabits.
Ja, also es ist wirklich ein Drama, dass man sich hier irgendwie ich meine, ich bin ja gerade in England und, und, und, und die Situation hier, äh, oh Gott, ist auch alles ganz furchtbar. Also, hier ist, hier ist es auch schlimm, vielleicht sogar noch schlimmer.
Großbritannien hat das ja Tradition irgendwie Infrastruktur wirklich in den Keller zu wirtschaften, oder? Also dass.
Ich wohne hier in einer äh äh Stadt, die eigentlich nur so zwei Stunden von äh der Hauptstadt London entfernt ist. Die gibt's auch schon seit ein paar hundert Jahren, länger eigentlich,
der Zug, der hier fährt, der ist immer noch Diesel betrieben. Es gibt hier noch nicht mal eine elektrifizierte Bahnlinie.
Großartig. Okay, das ist äh zum nächsten Thema kommen.
Okay.
Bevor wir jetzt hier über England raten.
Ja, das nächste Thema ist ähm.
Wir hatten in der letzten Sendung ja schon darüber berichtet, dass das ähm No-Spy-Abkommen eine, ja, bewusste,
Wahlkampflüge war,
wieder besseren Wissens wurde von Seiten der Bundesregierung behauptet, dass es irgendwie Optionen äh gäbe, ein solches Noseabkommen zu bekommen, dass es,
bald stattfinden würden, dass die Amerikaner gar ein solches Abkommen zugesichert hätten.
Und der veröffentlichte Schriftverkehr ähm zeigt hier äh das eindeutige Gegenteil, nämlich, dass die amerikanischen äh Unterhändler äh im Prinzip die ganze Zeit nur sagten, so geh weg.
Geweckt. Hört auf so was zu behaupten,
nein, das geht überhaupt nicht, nein, machen wir nicht. Wir können euch da nichts zusichern und auch schon wirklich sehr eindeutig äh immer wieder sagen, hört auf, so einen Unsinn zu zu verlangen oder zu behaupten, könnt ihr euch von der Backe putzen,
sie dann in dem ähm bitten des äh des deutschen
äh Verhandlungsführers oder Vertreters, der dann sagte, es wäre wirklich, wirklich
toll, wenn die äh amerikanische äh die US-Amerikanische Bundesregierung wenigstens irgendwie so etwas sagen könnte, wie ja, äh wir werden da uns mal drüber unterhalten. Das würde uns jetzt gerade sehr helfen.
Und ähm die Amerikaner dann irgendwie antworten. Nein, das werden wir nicht tun. Und den Höhepunkt erreichte das dann, glaube ich, als der deutsche Unterhändler versprach, den Begriff eines Norteabkommens nicht mehr zu verwenden. Ja? Und.
Ähm jetzt.
Ist die Frage, wie kam es denn, dass wir kurz vor der Bundestagswahl dann immer noch so äh stolz erzählt haben.
Oder erzählt bekommen haben, dass es äh dass ein solches Noteboy-Abkommen stattfinden wird. Und da fand sich jetzt ein äh sehr schöner ähm,
ein sehr schöner, kurzer, eine sehr schöne, kurze Aktennotiz mit dem mit den wenigen Worten lag der Kanzlerin vor, auf einem Dokument, äh wo äh eben.
Stand, ähm dass es äh,
Politik, dass die Politik über das Ob entscheiden müsste und dass man eben sehr weit davon entfernt ist. Das war das, was da eigentlich stand und da stand der Kanzlerin fordern, also sie wusste es.
Und hat da uns also mit einer Wahlkampflüge getäuscht.
Die Süddeutsche Zeitung hat sie dazu gefragt und er sagte, sagt, Angela Merkel einfach nur, natürlich nicht, es gab zwischen der Amerikaner zwischen der amerikanischen Seite und uns Gespräche, die es möglich erscheinen ließen, ein solches Abkommen zu vereinbaren.
Möglich erscheinen ließen, ein solches Abkommen zu vereinbaren. Also,
Ich finde das schon ein bisschen dreist.
Ja, ich meine, das ist.
Ein bisschen dreist.
Ja, das ist meine ähm ich denke, am Ende wird es wird das Scheitern ihr da irgendwas nachzu äh weisen. Man kann da jetzt sogar denken, was man äh will, aber ich meine, in ihrer teflon äh artigen äh Art und Weise aufzutreten, äh können wir schon denken, wie das läuft.
Sie können natürlich immer behaupten, dass sie irgendein internes Gespräch gehabt hat, was,
dokumentiert worden ist, äh weißt du, was ich äh auf irgendeiner höheren Ebene ähm nochmal über diese Aussagen hinweggesetzt hast? Ja, ich meine, wenn sie sagt, sie habe aber hier zwanzig Minuten mit Obama alleine im Raum gesessen.
Und er hat gesagt, na ja, Angi, wenn das und das ist so und der Himmel äh pink wird und so, dann hm, könnte man das vielleicht doch nochmal machen.
Himmel ist leider nicht pink geworden, sorry. Deswegen.
Also äh ich ich hoffe, dass sich die Schlinge dann doch doch noch ein bisschen enger zieht, denn ähm vorgestern Abend auf Netzpolitik org veröffentlicht, die Kommunikationslinie des,
Kanzleramt gegen Negativschlagzeilen in den North Spy Verhandlungen. Da gibt's also ein.
Ein äh Dokument, äh in dem äh die der Stand der Verhandlungen ähm,
geschildert wird und eine Kommunikationslinie
vorgeschlagen wird. Und so, wo eigentlich drin steht, die USA sind nicht bereit, äh unsere Petit zu berücksichtigen, ähm die Verhandlungen sind gescheitert, aber wir werden versuchen, sie fortzusetzen. Ähm.
Wörtlich steht ja diese Gespräche, wird die Bundesregierung fortführen bis bestehende Fragen in diesem Zusammenhang abschließend geklärt sind und ein aus deutscher Sicht zufriedenstellendes Ergebnis äh erzielt werden kann,
und ähm dann gibt's eben quasi so der Sachverhalt ist geschildert, die Bewertung und da steht dann also drin so, wir haben irgendwie keine.
Daneben sollten wir, das ist eigentlich das Spannende
trotz der negativen Äußerungen der US-Seite am Abschluss einer politischen Erklärung festhalten, die möglicherweise anlässlich ihres geplanten US-Besuchs öffentlich gemacht werden könnte,
Also da wieder diese Planung, ne? Wir können irgendwie den Leuten irgendwie etwas behaupten, dass wir dass wir da wären, dass es ein neues Abkommen gäbe oder so. Gleichzeitig sagen die USA die ganze Zeit wird's nicht geben.
Äh
Allerdings sollten wir darauf achten, dass von ihrer USA-Reise ein positiver Impuls für die künftige für das künftige transatlantische Verhältnis ausgeht, um klar kommunizieren, dass NSA nur ein Thema unter sehr vielen anderen ist, also auch da wieder diese ähm,
schöne äh Unterwürfigkeit gegen den USA.
Und dann eben die Kommunikationslinie, in der gesagt wird, ähm ja äh wir wollen jetzt, wir haben jetzt,
gehobenen Posten des Staatssekretärs für die Nachrichtendienste und wo ist es?
Während der Diskussion wurde das gemeinsame Verständnis deutlich, dass die Nachrichtendienstliche Kooperation nicht uneingeschränkt alle technischen Möglichkeiten, die zur Verfügung stehen, nutzen kann, sondern sich nach Recht und Gesetz dem politischen Freiheit und den Schutz der Privatsphäre zu richten hat.
Diese Gespräche wird die Bundesregierung fortführen.
Auch in den USA hat die äh Diskussion zur Abwägung sicher, der sich zwischen Sicherheitsinteressen und Schutz der Privatsphäre begonnen.
Und ja, also du siehst halt, sie wussten es, sie haben
Also der, der, der Kern der Sache ist halt, sie, sie wussten, dass es vor die Wand läuft und sie haben sich quasi schon extra mit einer Kommunikationslinie genau darauf vorbereitet. Und ich hoffe,
dass ja das wenigstens ähm solche Äußerungen von Angela Merkel, die dann sagt, ja es gab irgendwie äh.
Gute Aussicht auf solche Gespräche, das war keine Wahlkampflüge, die das eben auch einfach mal.
Jetzt wirklich zeigen, dass es eben nicht so ist. So, das ist äh denen war das die ganze Zeit klar.
Hm. Ja gut, also das ist so die die Dokumentlage, dass äh uns als zeigt sich das
eigentlich relativ deutlich, dass die hier einfach ins Nichts ähm diskutiert haben, aber wie groß das Empörungspotenzial da in der Öffentlichkeit ist, ist man dann noch nicht so ganz klar,
Was ja unser Empörungspotenzial ist ein bisschen größer. Bisschen.
Aber ich meine, ich ich werde nicht müde, das zu betonen. Also ich meine, in es ist wirklich ein, ein, ein wirklich ein großer Skandal, dass,
quasi in diesem Bereich dann ähm also rückblickend, ja, also immer wieder auf das Gesamtbild achten, ja, die,
irgendwelche Merkel-Handy-Aufreger, wo wir wo dann irgendwie gesagt wird, aus ausspionieren unter Freunden geht gar nicht. Und ähm versucht wird,
so eine leichte ähm,
Also es ist schon auf diese diese anti-amerikanischen äh Ressentiments so ein bisschen zu setzen, die gleichzeitig aber natürlich möglichst klein zu halten und die Nähe zu den USA zu suchen, die Leute noch anzulügen. Also das ist das ist wirklich
Ey, das ist sowas von ekelhaft, ja, also das äh
Das sind so das sind so richtig schöne Verschwörungstheorien, die da äh genährt werden und das wird auch nochmal unabhängig davon.
Wie wir das jetzt sehen und das ist auch wirklich ein Skandal ist, auch nochmal ganz andere ähm
Probleme für die Bundesregierung und die Glaubwürdigkeit der Bundesregierung und vor allem für die Politikverdrossenheit in diesem Land bringen, wenn wir ähm eben
derart mit derartigen Lügen ähm verarscht werden.
Ähm und jetzt hier gleich gänzlich in die äh Rolle des äh Teufels Arthurs Karten äh schlüpfen zu wollen, aber was mich auch interessiert, siehst du das.
Was denkst du, wie steht die Bundesregierung gerade da? Im auf dem internationalen Parkett.
Also wie stark oder wie schwach ist die Rolle von Deutschland.
In diesen ganzen diplomatischen Gesamtgefüge. Denn,
ähm vielleicht nix nichts schönreden, sondern ich versuche nur so ein bisschen zu verstehen, was so äh die was so eigentlich die Motivation ist für dieses ganze Geeier, ja. Ähm.
Sicherlich sehen die ja auch, dass sie in der Öffentlichkeit dort aktiv an Glaubwürdigkeit verlieren. Vielleicht na, sieht der ein oder andere auch ähm da schon das Ganze.
So, dass es sich zu weit entwickelt hätte. Nur mal so unter als Unterstellung. Trotzdem gibt es halt immer diesen diplomatischen Gegendruck.
Stehst dann irgendwie so einer amerikanischen Delegation gegenüber, die halt einfach.
Eine ganze Batterie von äh Themen in der Hinterhand hat, die ganzen äh
militärischen Fragen, die ganzen Sicherheitsfragen, die ganzen äh wirtschaftlichen äh Debatten, die im Rahmen laufen, die ja dann wahrscheinlich in jeder Diskussion auch immer wieder zusammengeworfen werden, ne? Und gerade diese Geheimdienst umfasst halt irgendwie alles
und da äh existiert vermutlich einfach ein extrem starker Druck.
Was wie wie stellst du dir das vor? Also was äh was was glaubst du, was die da in Anführungsstrichen durchmachen müssen?
Also ich habe wenig Mitleid mit dem mit der Bundesregierung, für das, was sie durchmachen muss. Ähm ich, also.
Wir sehen ja so ein bisschen welche Länder sich jetzt eben äh gegen diese ähm,
Geheimdienst Spionage, die dann eben von äh Deutschland auch ausging in der Zusammenarbeit zwischen BND und Deutscher Telekom für sechstausend Euro im Monat, äh unter Beteiligung der NSA.
Ähm da sehen wir jetzt halt so,
kleinere äh Länder, kleinere Staaten mit vermutlich geringeren ähm Geheimdienstbudgets äh aus denen sich jetzt Oppositionsparteien ähm melden und ähm,
oder kleinere Parteien melden und äh Strafanzeigen anstrengen. Insgesamt glaube ich, dass sorry.
Welche Länder sind das jetzt? Welche Länder sind das?
Österreich,
Luxemburg und was weiß noch, waren die Niederlande jetzt dabei? Nee, das war ein anderes Land. Ich bin da so schlecht in Geografie. Wir hatten letzte Woche die drei Länder genannt. Ähm.
Und es scheint doch so ein bisschen so zu sein,
diese gesamte, also wenn du dann nochmal zurückdenkst an diese enorme Zahl der Kooperationen mit internationalen Geheimdiensten, die der BND da hat. Ähm da erscheint mir doch insgesamt, dass so zu sein, dass die.
Dass die Regierungen, also naja, die Geheimdienste kooperieren da irgendwie so, machen ihr Ding. Ähm.
Reagieren eigentlich absolut im rechtsfreien Raum. Die Regierung wissen vielleicht auch wirklich nicht so viel darüber
weil die Geheimdienstchen ja nicht so viel erzählen. Und dann ist es letztendlich, sobald du,
ein wirklich rechtsfreien Raum hast, ja, in dem keine nennenswerten Kontroll- oder Sanktionsmöglichkeiten mehr bestehen, dann hast du,
der Regel sowas wie Faustrecht beziehungsweise rechte Stärke. Das heißt, derjenige oder diejenige ähm,
Institutionen oder derjenige Geheimdienst, der die meiste Macht hat, ähm hat natürlich auch überhaupt gar keine Veranlassung, die nicht auszunutzen.
Und ähm ich glaube genau nach diesem Muster.
Laufen dann eben auch die Verhandlungen unter diesen Geheimdiensten. Die versuchen natürlich alle zu machen, was sie können, haben versuchen natürlich auch gegenseitig herauszufinden, was der andere kann.
Und die USA haben einfach ein ein stattliches Budget und damit die Möglichkeit, mit äh mit jedem Geheimdienst oder mit fast jedem Geheimdienst dieser Erde äh,
Kooperationen einzugehen und zwar nach ihren Vorgaben. Letztendlich ist da in dem Verhältnis äh zu den USA, der,
der deutsche Auslandsgeheimdienst BND
nicht wirklich anders gestellt als vielleicht ein ein österreichischer Geheimdienst, weil die USA eben entsprechende Daten aus allen Ländern haben wollen. Und der eine Geheimdienst kann halt ein bisschen was in die Waagschale legen und der andere auch ein bisschen was. Letztendlich ähm sind aber die Überwachungskapaz,
und Fähigkeiten der USA eben äh enorm,
und es sowohl aus diplomatischen Erwägungen, als auch aus äh strategischen Erwägungen, nicht ratsam, mit denen nicht zu kooperieren.
Ähm und so kommt es dann, dass sich höchstens mal.
Wenn man dann feststellt, okay Deutschland äh innerhalb Europas hat innerhalb Europas spioniert gegen die Nachbarstaaten, dass sich dann eben mal ein ähm.
Ja, die kleineren Parteien melden und sagen, ey, so jetzt reicht's aber mal langsam wirklich. Allerdings auch nur, weil es dann wieder
der weil offenbar in dem Moment eben Deutschland eine Kapazität ausgenutzt hat die die sich gegen Österreich richten ließ. Ich,
Mal gespannt und ich bin darüber auch nicht in Kenntnis, welche,
theoretischen Optionen, äh die österreichischen Geheimdienste haben zur internationalen Spionage, aber da äh sei ja wieder mal auf den.
Experten Erich Möchel verwiesen, der da in Wien äh entsprechend untersucht, was äh internationale ähm.
Äh Botschaften und Konsulate und Niederlassung da so auf den Dächern haben. Also die kooperieren alle, wie gesagt, ich glaube wirklich, dieser,
dass dieser internationale Spionage-Verbund wahrscheinlich echt der der größte internationale, friedliche Zusammenschluss ist, den es gibt.
Die Bundesregierung, ja, gegenüber den USA haben die halt auch nichts zu sagen. Und sind da natürlich, und das, das, das sieht man auch aus dieser Kommunikationsleitlinie, diese Abwägung, dass sie sagen,
Wir müssen irgendwie den Eindruck wahren, dass wir hier für irgendwas gewählt wurden, wo wir mit Souveränität agieren können.
Und ähm gleichzeitig müssen wir unbedingt vermeiden, dass wir uns, dass wir es uns irgendwie mit den Amerikanern verhageln.
Und so ist das, glaube ich, in in allen Bereichen, wo ähm wo es einfach keine.
Keine Motivation gibt,
freiwillig auf irgendetwas Rücksicht zu nehmen und auch keine Sanktionsmöglichkeiten gibt äh irgendwelche Regeln ähm zu forcieren. Und dann hast du automatisch halt das Recht des Stärkeren.
Ja, das heißt äh letzten Endes müssen wir darauf hoffen, dass äh die Revolution vielleicht von innen kommt.
Da würde mir auch das was zu einfallen, nämlich äh wie wäre es denn, wenn auf einmal die Kontrollgremien äh Alarm schlagen?
Das ist eine sehr schöne Überleitung. Ähm.
Es gibt ja öffentlich immer noch eine große Debatte. Die hält auch grade noch an, um die Untersuchung beziehungsweise Veröffentlichung,
Einsicht der Selektorenlisten. Gemeint sind damit die jene, ähm Suchbegriffe und Selektoren, die die.
NSA an den BND übertragen hat und die dann in irgendwelchen zufälligen Kontrollen viel zu spät irgendwann mal als äh potenziell äh vielleicht nicht ganz in Übereinkunft mit europäischen oder deutschen Interessen identifiziert wurden.
Ähm und jene Selektoren ähm,
möchten ja jetzt alle möglichen interessierten Gremien gerne mal sehen. Eines der interessierten Gremien ist äh der die Redaktion von Lokbuch Netzpolitik. Ähm natürlich aber auch
die äh die äh die G zehn Kommission und auch der NSA Untersuchungsausschuss. Und ähm,
Ich glaube, im NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss war die Antwort ja ungefähr so, ja sorry, wir haben mal die Amis gefragt, ob wir das machen dürfen, aber die haben gesagt, nein. Sorry.
Also so ungefähr lief das, glaube ich, da ab. Ähm.
Es gibt jetzt grade as we Speak weitere Debatten ähm darüber, äh wie man denn eventuell eine eine Einsicht äh ermöglichen könnte, dass,
da weiß ich nicht, wie viel ich da jetzt grade öffentlich zu sagen kann, aber also das ist gerade der Toppic so. Man will diese Selektorenlisten sehen und natürlich ähm ist die Bundesregierung ähm auf maximale Abwehr geschaltet ähm
dass da bloß, wer auch immer die jemals zu sehen kriegt, ähm.
Niemals öffentlich darüber, äh über deren Inhalte redet. Diese Sicherheit haben sie bei den Geheimdiensten, Mitarbeitern, die mit ihren
die damit agiert haben, weil die eben auch entsprechenden Geheimhaltungspflichten unterliegen und man die eben, die sich quasi wahrscheinlich ihr,
Pension und ihr ihren Lebensabend ruinieren würden, wenn sie ähm daraus irgendwie etwas äh öffentlich bekannt machen.
Und jetzt müssen wir irgendwie als Gesellschaft so überlegen, ähm ob wir die wirklich veröffentlichen können oder welche vertrauenswürdige Person sie einsehen kann und äh die vor die,
Idee der Bundesregierung ist natürlich irgendwie möglichst wenn überhaupt, dann nur irgendwelche Leute darein blicken zu lassen, die mit allen möglichen Sicherheitsüberprüfungen und
äh ähm
Geheimhaltungsvereinbarung, gesegnet sind und dann eben wieder rausgehen können und sagen, ich kann mit niemandem drüber reden, ähnlich wie die G zehn Kommission. Äh und das parlamentarische Kontrollgremium, aber auch jene.
Dürfen diese Selektorenlisten bis heute nicht einsehen,
woraufhin die G zehn Kommission? Wir erinnern uns, den Fehler mache ich kein zweites Mal, welche dafür zuständig ist, Überwachungsmaßnahmen der Geheimdienste zu bewilligen,
wenn diese eventuell auch Deutsche betroffen betreffen könnten. Ähm die äh der Name geht auf den Grundgesetz, Artikel zehn,
zurück, in dem eben Briefpost- und Fernmeldegeheimnis festgeschrieben sind. Das heißt, eine Geheimdienstmaßnahme, die potenziell oder dieses Potential innehat, äh Briefpost und Fernmeldegeheimnis zu verletzen und oder Fernmeldegeheimnis zu verletzen, äh muss von der G zehn,
abgesegnet werden. Und jetzt hat die G zehn Kommission letzte Woche angekündigt,
Ja äh BND, wenn ihr hier nächste Mal vorbeikommt, werden wir euch keine Überwachung mehr genehmigen, bis wir nicht die Selektorenliste gesehen haben.
Hm
Und das ist natürlich echt spannend. Also jetzt.
Ist ja auch logisch vor allem, nicht? Also ich meine.
Es ist logisch, weil sie sagen können, okay, ähm wir haben keine Ahnung, was ob bei euch die Integrität der der Datenverarbeitung äh und Speicherung und Einsicht gesichert ist. Insofern können wir nicht davon ausgehen.
Ähm dass äh dass dass wir euch eine solche Maßnahme genehmigen können. Wir wollen erst diese Selektoren sehen.
Ja, vor allem die Maßnahme selber definiert sich ja im Prinzip auch durch diese Lektoren. Man findet es immer gibt's eigentlich irgendwelche Erkenntnisse dadrüber, in welcher Form diese Selektoren vorliegen?
Also wovon reden wir, reden wir von Suchbegriffen, Keywords, SQL, äh Strings.
Also die da ich gehe mal die schiere Menge der äh Selektoren liegt nahe, dass es sich um ein ähm,
Computer, lesbares Format handelt und ähm ich stelle mir das äh so vor, äh dass das eben
Suchbegriffe auf verschiedenen Ebenen sind, ne? Also wir hatten ja schon
herausgefunden, dass es sich eben um IP-Adressen, um Meckadressen, um äh Telefonnummer, Namen und so weiter, E-Mail-Adressen handeln kann, also auf den verschiedenen.
Auf den verschiedenen Layern der Kommunikation äh entsprechende äh Suchfilter eingegeben werden können. Und,
ich würde jetzt ehrlich gesagt vermuten, dass das ähm eine vereinfachte ähm,
Suchanfrage ist, ne? Also wahrscheinlich eine CSV, wo man oder so eine Jason oder irgendwie was
man heute macht. Ich weiß nicht, wie hip äh die äh Systeme sind, die äh Geheimdienste dann nutzen. Aber ich denke, dass du dann relativ einfaches äh,
relativ einfache Sprache für Hass, ja? Muss ja dann auch von allen möglichen Analysten,
bedienbar sein, die eben nicht äh so Hardcore-Tackies sind. Und die werden halt wahrscheinlich eine eine schöne Oberfläche haben, wo sie sagen, hier äh interessiert mich Selektor.
Ja gut, aber meine Frage ging eigentlich, äh, in die Richtung mit, ist schon mal eine solche Liste als solche oder ein Selektor mal als solcher dokumentiert worden. Also, gibt's da irgendwo mal.
Es gibt ja nee, also nicht, es sei denn, es ist der gleiche wie diese dieses Ex-Kiescore-Format, wo vor,
mindestens einem Jahr ähm über die Betreiber von Tornotes äh.
Und die IP-Adressen von Trainotes ähm damals Fragmente geliebt oder veröffentlicht wurden vom, ich glaube, äh Spiegel, wenn ich das jetzt recht entsinne, ist mir schon zu lange her, aber da waren im Prinzip,
Da erinnere ich mich an so eine.
Sprache und das war so ungefähr die interne Sprache von exkiescore. Alles jetzt aus meinem ähm kaputten Langzeitgedächtnis zusammengereimt, aber es gibt quasi also es gab schon mal einen Fall, wo,
Vereinzelte Fragmente dieser Selektorensprache veröffentlicht wurden. Das war, wenn ich das jetzt recht entsinne, einfach irgendwie so ein bisschen geschweiffte Klammern und gebe ihm.
Ähm jetzt sind wir ein bisschen abgeschweißt, so, aber,
Jetzt wäre natürlich, wie jetzt wiederum, ein BND-Mitarbeiter, der sich diese Selektoren anschaut, das wieder extrahiert, ob der das dann in der,
ob die austauschbar zwischen BND und NSA an der Stelle exkiescore ist, was ich vermuten würde, weil
ist ja eigentlich dem BND darum ging Exkiescore nutzen zu können, deswegen würde ich jetzt spontan vermuten, dass sie da äh,
sage ich mal, standardisierte Schnittstellen haben, ohne viel äh Schmu
und das relativ einfach alles funktioniert. Ob jetzt aber der Geheimdienstmitarbeiter, der die Suchbegriffe da rausgefunden hat, die irgendwie
missliebig sind, in welchem Dateiformat der das jetzt wieder abgespeichert hat oder ob er's nicht vielleicht sowieso schon aus Versehen gelöscht hat, wie wahrscheinlich wir bald erfahren werden, dass er auf mehreren Disketten verteilt. Keiner ups gelöscht.
Ja? Mussten wir ja löschen. Ähm das weiß ich nicht, aber ähm ich würde jetzt vermuten, dass der da ja,
anfänglichen oder die ersten Verdachte erschienen ja durch das Suchen nach Gof und DE wenn ich mich nicht täusche und da hat er wahrscheinlich einfach irgendwie durchgekreppt und ähm,
Wie sieht dann das Ergebnis aus?
Mhm.
Äh Spekulation. Ähm.
Ja, jetzt die Frage, wie wird jetzt reagiert auf diese Weigerung der G zehn Kommission?
Werden wir sehen, denn äh die am Mittwoch, also vor zwei Tagen, hat die äh G zehn Kommission dann zwei äh über,
Wachungsanträge des BND abgelehnt. Also die machen jetzt offenbar ernst.
Und da ging es natürlich um, ist ja klar, da geht's ja dann um internationalen Kinderhandel und äh und Uran Import, ist natürlich klar, geht's ja immer.
Oder irgendwie sowas in der Art, ne? Ähm und.
Ist auf jeden Fall.
Was ganz wichtig ist, wir werden alle sterben. Und ähm jetzt werden wir mal schauen.
Also wer ist, ich find's auch ganz interessant, weil du jetzt natürlich man kann ja auch argumentieren, ähm dass,
diese Selektoren,
ja nun mit einer neuen Überwachungsmaßnahme erstmal überhaupt nichts zu tun haben. Es geht dabei um Selektoren der, die in der Vergangenheit ähm aufgefallen sind und die,
seitdem ja auch nicht mehr zum Einsatz kommen. Das muss man ja auch dazu sagen. Ähm die äh äh
filtern diese Selektoren ja und haben die dann eben auch entsprechend zurückgewiesen. Es war nur sehr lange, dass sie da eben.
Möglichst nicht draufgeschaut haben und dann immer mal wieder irgendjemand, der mal kurz drauf geblickt hat,
gesagt hat, hm, ein bisschen komisch hier und dann eben von oben gesagt wurde, hä, Schnauze. So, so, so lief es da ja ab, aber die offizielle äh Verlautbarung ist ja, dass diese Selektoren nicht mehr zum Einsatz kommen. Also mit welcher ähm.
Mit welcher also die Begründung für die G zehn Kommission diese Überwachungsmaßnahmen jetzt abzulehnen bis sie irgendwelche Selektoren der Vergangenheit gesehen hat, steht da glaube ich auf
etwas dünner äh argumentativer Grundlage. Andererseits können sie natürlich sagen, hier ähm,
Wie ich gerade schon sagte, euch ist grundsätzlich nicht zu trauen, dass man erstmal schauen, wie wie bei euch da überhaupt die Zusammenarbeit läuft. Denn ähm vielleicht ist euch grundsätzlich nicht mehr
nix mitzutrauen. Was ich nicht weiß, ist, ob die Geheimdienste jetzt vielleicht gegen die G zehn Kommission klagen können.
Da da bin ich bin ich mir nicht äh da das weiß ich nicht. Ich fänd's auf jeden Fall lustig.
Ich schaue gerade mal, wer eigentlich in der G zehn Kommission ist. Ist äh eine interessante Liste von mir weitgehend unbekannten Menschen, muss ich sagen.
Und zwar sind das derzeit Andreas Schmidt, ein CDU-Politiker. Berthold Huber, ein Jurist, der offensichtlich keiner Partei angehört. Frank Hoffmann von der SPD.
Und ein Ulrich Maurer äh.
Auch Jurist, SPD, später die Linke. Ah, okay, das heißt, der ist jetzt bei die Linke. Das ist sozusagen die G zehn Kommission.
Da geht's nach drei, vier Stellvertreter.
Dann gibt es noch Stellvertreter, das sind äh bekanntere Namen in der Tat. Wolfgang Wieland, Burkat Lischka, die SPD, Wolfgang Götzer von der CSU und äh Linken.
Ich weiß aber nicht, wann diese Vorstellvertreter überhaupt zum zum Zuge kommen. Ist das jetzt nur ein Krankheitsfall oder so? Keine Ahnung. Na ja, auf jeden Fall,
da hat sich sozusagen ein aus CDU und SPD und unabhängigen zusammengesetzte Kommission etwas quer gestellt. Ist ja auch schon mal was.
Ich bin jetzt mal gespannt, ähm das ist auf jeden Fall mal eine interessante ähm Zuspitzung. Ähm.
Bin mal gespannt, ob die ihren Informationsbedarf durch diese Maßnahme ähm denken können.
Die äh Rebellion in der zweiten und äh dritten Reihe. Die gab's ja auch in den USA ein bisschen, ne?
Ja, der äh Patriot-Act wurde nicht verlängert. Ähm.
Und zwar geht es äh insbesondere um die zweihundertfünfzehn. Ähm des äh Patfit Acts und äh da ging es jetzt also mal wieder um die Verlängerung, die ja eigentlich bisher in dem äh,
US-Kongress eine eine.
So ein ein Standardprozess war ähm und jetzt wurde mal nachgefragt. Das FBI konnte nicht einen einzigen äh Wirksamkeitsbeleg für den Patriot-Act äh,
vorbringen und ähm ein ähm.
Ein äh Gesetzesentwurf, eben diesen diesen äh Patriot-Act zu verlängern. Äh wurde abgelehnt.
So und jetzt äh ist ab dem einen ist mit dem mit Mitternacht vom einunddreißigsten Mai der Patriot-Act äh mit dieser Section außer Kraft und man wird sehen, ähm,
wie lange das dauert, bis die sich wieder einkriegen und irgendetwas verlängern.
Aber ich fand's auf jeden Fall mal ganz interessant, dass äh da eine Verlängerung eben nicht stattgefunden hat. Zunächst ähm ich glaube schon, dass das etwas ist, was ähm also dass ich könnte mir schwer vorstellen, dass das.
Ähm ein ein Dauerzustand bleibt und ähm dass sie jetzt versuchen, irgendetwas anderes zu finden, aber im Moment ist der Patriot-Act erstmal offenbar außer Kraft.
Ich glaube, der Patriot-Act war wahrscheinlich auch ähm in der Öffentlichkeit auch so vom Namen her ziemlich verbrannt. So, weil der Stand natürlich,
jetzt nicht genau, wie das in den USA so gesehen wird. International ist das natürlich auf jeden Fall schon so. Der Patriot-Act ist eigentlich so der,
für diese gnadenlose Rückschlags äh und und Revanche-Mentalität, die die USA halt nach den Anschlägen äh von zwanzig äh zweitausendeins ähm,
irgendwie ausgemacht hat in der Öffentlichkeit
nicht? Also Überfall auf den Irak und überhaupt dieses ganze äh militärische Getöse und äh natürlich auch diese komplette
innere Mobilmachung, ja, die dann so Mcartig irgendwie auf den äh alles, was irgendwie Islam ist, eingeschlagen hat. Das.
Dafür steht halt dieser nicht zuletzt, weil er eben auch teilweise eben auch die die rechtliche Grundlage für viele äh dieser Maßnahmen war
Und äh das hat sicherlich dazu geführt, dass äh auch hier ein wenig Unterstützung weggegangen ist. Aber ist ja jetzt auch nicht so, dass der Patriot Act komplett ersatzlos gestrichen worden wäre.
Genau, also der der entscheidende Punkt ist, es geht ja nicht um den gesamten Patriote-Act, sondern eben um die Sektion zweihundertfünfzehn. Und das war eben
die im Prinzip zentralisierte NSA-Sammlung von Vorratsdaten,
Ja, also nur um die geht es, ja? Die die Amerikaner interessieren sich ja wie alle anderen auch, ähm natürlich erstmal vorrangig um ihre eigene äh um ihren eigenen,
Schutz vor Datenerfassung und es geht in diesem Falle nur um die Sexion zweihundertfünfzehn, die eben die Vorratsdatenspeicherung betrifft.
Und dieser Teil wurde Ende Mai nicht verlängert.
Während und das hat die US-Regierung dann auch ähm hingenommen. Gleichzeitig wurde dann der.
Zwischenzeitlich ja schon tot geglaubte ähm Freedom-Act beschlossen.
Und der Freedom-Act, das ist das, was wir ähm was wir ähm schon vor langer Zeit mal besprochen haben.
Diese sehr schwache ähm Reform der in den USA, äh wo man sagt, okay, wir werden die Vorratsdaten nicht mehr bei der NSA sammeln.
Sondern wir etablieren eine ähm.
Wir etablieren eine dezentrale Vorratsdatenspeicherung, bei der die Regierung dann bei den Telefon Providern konkret anfragen muss.
Im Prinzip das Modell, was jetzt in Deutschland ähm gerade in ähnlicher Form eingeführt werden soll.
Also die Downgraden gerade auf.
Das deutsche Modell.
Auf das auf das europäische deutsche Modell. Das ist.
Bisher die einzige wirkliche Änderung auf US-Seite,
dass sie ihre Vorratsdatenspeicherung dezentralisiert haben. Ähm entsprechend sind natürlich auch die ähm die Kommentare der Bürgerrechtsorganisation, äh die quasi sagen, ja ähm.
Einerseits.
Ist das natürlich ein ein viel zu kleiner Schritt, um kein Grund zu feiern. Aber genau deshalb ist es umso wichtiger, dass wir genau diesen kleinen Schritt wenigstens mal gehen. Ja, und um dann ähm weiterzumachen. Ähm.
Das heißt, sie kritisieren einerseits wie ähm.
Wie wie schwach dieser Gesetzes diese Gesetzesänderung ist und sagen aber gleichzeitig, natürlich ist sie aber gerade deshalb umso notwendiger auf jeden Fall äh angenommen zu werden. Und das ist jetzt auch ähm passiert.
Gut, schauen wir mal, wie glücklich äh die USA damit äh werden.
So, dann war da noch irgendwas mit so einer äh da war doch, da war doch was los. Da war doch äh da gab's auch richtig äh Thermik, da waren doch.
Hm? Irgendwas war doch. Irgendwas ist irgendwas war doch vielleicht passiert.
Irgendwas war vielleicht passiert. Ähm.
Wir hatten in der letzten Folge uns noch darüber beklagt, wie absolut unterirdisch und unklar die äh Kommunikation der
äh Bund des Bundestages, der Bundesregierung oder des äh Bundestagsparlaments zu dem noch nie dagewesenen Hackerangriff noch die noch nie dagewesenen Ausmaßes auf ihre Systeme war. Ähm,
anfänglich war da ja irgendwie von Ausfall und Dedos die Rede, das äh zeigte sich ja dann auch relativ bald, als der Humbug ähm als den wir es auch eigentlich vermutet haben, es scheint sich jetzt herauszukristallisieren, dass es sich da in dem Fall,
einen äh Trojaner äh angefandelt auf ähm Rechner des deutschen äh Bundestages.
Und ähm es gibt ja auch schon die äh,
Bestätigung, dass äh ein Datenabfluss stattgefunden hätte, meines Wissens werden die Bundestagsabgeordneten und ihre Mitarbeiter da im Moment noch unter ähm sehr.
Einer sehr äh eingeschränkten Informationspolitik gehalten, das heißt denen wird relativ wenig gesagt, ja?
Ähm es wurde aber wohl ein deutscher ähm Dienstleister äh
beauftragt mit der forensischen Untersuchung dieses Vorfalls und ähm es wurde mir so bedeutet, dass es sich da um jemanden handelt, der ähm durchaus in dem Bereich kompetent ist,
Da haben sie also vermutlich nicht absolut ins Klo gegriffen.
Und die Sache wird jetzt ähm forensisch untersucht und ähm das Erste, was natürlich klar war, äh es war der Russe,
Kanja können ja nur die Russen gewesen sein. Ähm.
Denn mit denen äh ist ja gerade Krieg und ähm Eurasien äh war ja schon immer im Krieg mit äh uns.
Also ich ich stelle mir das gerade.
Hm?
Ja, also ähm IT-Experten ist es gelungen, dieses dieses Spähprogramm zu identifizieren und Teile des Quellcodes zu reversen,
und da wird gesagt, die Programmstruktur ähnlich einer Schadsoftware, die bereits zweitausendvierzehn bei einem Cyberangriff auf ein deutsches Datennetz zum Einsatz gekommen war
und damals wurde ebenfalls ein ausländischer Nachrichtendienst hinter dem Angriff vermutet.
Und jetzt sieht es irgendwie so aus, äh als seien diese vereinzelten Datenanflüsse aus dem,
Palakom, dem Parlament, parlamentarische Kommunikationssystem des Bundestages eben.
Ja, in Richtung Russland gegangen. Ähm natürlich ist,
vielleicht nochmal, da sollte man auch mal ein bisschen zu ausholen, also zu atribuieren.
Von wem man eine solche Schadsoftware jetzt bekommen hat, ist grundsätzlich relativ schwierig. Ja, also so eine Schadsoftware sitzt da, die muss irgendwie oder die wird irgendwie sich Befehle holen,
dafür also sie wird einen Rückkanal haben zu dem Angreifer.
Wenn der Angreifer jetzt besonders blöd ist, dann nimmt er da halt einfach irgendeine IP für, die vielleicht zu ihm gehört oder sogar auf seinen Namen registriert ist. Ähm so blöd sind aber Angreifer ähm heute nicht mehr.
Sondern,
setzen da eben auf auf andere Möglichkeiten der sogenannten Kommunikation. Ähm eine naheliegende und einfache Möglichkeit ist es natürlich zum Beispiel den Rückkanal durch äh Tor laufen zu lassen.
Oder äh wenn man eh schon ähm im Hacking so sportlich ist, dass man ähm.
Sage ich mal, seine eigene so schreibt, dass sie von anderen nicht erkannt wird und damit äh Parlamente
anderer Staaten oder seines eigenen Staates zu infizieren, dann kann man sich natürlich auch zum Beispiel überlegen, ob man seine Commanden control äh.
Oder die das extrahieren von Daten eben durch andere gehackte Systeme macht.
Man kann da schön ähm man kann da schön verschlüsseln. Also es ist relativ schwierig am Ende zu sagen, okay oder es es ist nicht möglich, am Ende zu sagen, okay, der Trojanerfunk nach China, ähm das waren also die Chinesen.
Ja oder kommt aus Russland, genauso
das kann genauso gut gekaperte Systeme sein, von denen das ausging. Und dann geht es einfach über Bande, über äh mehrere Sachen. Kann sogar sein, dass der Bundestag jetzt äh andere Parlamente angegriffen hat, ohne es selber zu wissen, eben genau durch diese Trojaner, ja.
Man halt nicht.
Eine Option, die aber natürlich ganz interessant ist, ist, wenn man den, äh wenn man die Binärdatei,
die man ja zweifelsohne auf den infizierten Systemen grade ausführt, wenn man die ähm dis-assembliert oder zu teilen versucht, zu verstehen
und dann erkennt, okay, ähm wir finden hier Programmcode in diesem Bereich, in diesem Bereich und in diesem Bereich, den wir vielleicht an anderer Stelle schon einmal gesehen haben,
oder wir erkennen, dass äh bestimmte Teile in diesem Programm
in sind, ja, oder so. Ähm es gibt also relativ viele ähm.
Hinweise, die sich in so einem kompelierten Programm noch finden lassen, die eventuell auf die,
Muttersprache oder den Ort des äh Programmierers äh oder des bauenden Systemes Rückschlüsse nahelegen. Gleichzeitig kann man davon ausgehen, dass äh Geheimdienste darüber auch wissen,
Und unter Umständen eben solche äh falsche Fährten absichtlich legen. Äh es sei hier aber daran erinnert, dass sich.
Das ist doch diesen modularen, wie hieß der denn? Oh, wie hieß dieser Trojaner? Ähm.
Ähm der US-amerikanische modulare Trojaner, irgendwas mit Teflon oder sowas, der hatte keinen äh wie hieß der denn?
Ein modulare Trojaner.
Müssen wir mal kurz googeln Regin.
Wenn ich mich nicht äh Regien Trojaner, wo man sagte, okay, das ist im Prinzip eine so eine,
Ganze sweet.
An ähm an an Modulen, wo man also sagt, okay, wenn wir jetzt ein ein Windows-Computer äh angreifen in einem,
weil
was weiß ich, bei Siemens oder so in der Fertigung, dann wollen wir halt äh Module haben, wollen wir Module mit einbauen, die eben in, in irgendwelchen Skada und Industrie vier null System sich auskennen. Wenn wir aber einen Mobilfunk Provider angreifen, dann wollen wir natürlich dessen
äh ungesicherten, ungesichertes Management-Netzwerk für diese ähm.
Für die Telekommunikationsinfrastruktur angreifen und nicht alles, was wir können, muss immer mit eingebaut sein, wenn wir jemanden infizieren. Und ähm da stellte sich ja dann auch heraus, dass äh,
quasi der Belger kommen, Hack,
Überschneidungen hatte mit diesem Trojaner, den man an anderer Stelle gefunden hatte. Und wenn du feststellst, dass du Module darin findest, die du an anderer Stelle schon auch gesehen hast oder die eine zu hohe Ähnlichkeit haben
um noch zufällig zu sein in ihrer in ihrem funktionalen
Aufbau, dann kannst du natürlich schon Ähnlichkeit oder Verwandtschaften zwischen Trojanern herstellen. Insofern ist es nicht auszuschließen, dass eine ausreichend lange, forensische Analyse von jemandem, der sehr viel
in dieser Hinsicht schon gemacht hat und der lange in diesem Geschäft ist, durchaus mal zu Tage führen, ähm dass,
mit an Sicherheit grenzender Wahrscheinlichkeit ein Trojaner, der gefunden wurde aus der Hand
desgleichen Teames stammt wie ein anderer Trojaner, der gefunden wurde, äh aus der Feder des gleichen Teams stammt, wie ein anderer Trojaner, der gefunden wurde und man dann zumindest sagen kann, okay, das ist hier der das war das gleiche Autorenteam,
oder sogar da sind große Teile übernommen worden äh und ähnlich in den, in den beiden Programmen. Und wenn man dann irgendwann genug ähm.
Anhaltspunkte hat, woher denn diese unterschiedlichen Angriffe gekommen sind oder wohin die abgeflossen sind, dann kann man irgendwann so eine Aussage treffen, wie äh es waren.
Vermutlich Akteure aus diesem oder jenem Land.
Aber zu diesem Zeitpunkt ist das eigentlich,
sehr unlauter, also eine Feststellung zu machen, beziehungsweise auf jeden Fall äh macht es den Eindruck, als könnte diese Aussage doch politisch gefärbt sein, so nach dem Motto, wir brauchen jetzt hier mal wieder ein plausibles Angriffsszenario äh und wenn man halt heute äh Russland sagt, dann dann
nicken halt alle.
Also der der Klassiker ist ja, dass du sagst, okay, die Daten fließen nach China ab, also waren's die Amis. Weil die Amis natürlich äh gehackte, chinesische
nehmen, um die Spuren zu verwischen und wenn die Chinesen angreifen, dann, dann nutzen sie natürlich
der amerikanische Computer. Und es könnte natürlich irgendwie so sein, dass der Forensika da sitzt und sagt die Daten gehen nach China, das kann alles heißen und dann sitzt so der der Pressevertreter neben ihm und sagt so, das heißt, es könnten auch die Russen gewesen sein und dann sagt der Forensiker,
kann ich zu diesem Zeitpunkt nicht ausschließen und dann rennen die nach vorne und sagen, wann die Russen. Ja, also.
Es kann aber natürlich auch genauso gut sein, dass da wirklich jemanden mit ähm.
Langjähriger Erfahrung äh sitzt der tatsächlich vielleicht auch schon ähnliche Programme gesehen hat und daher vielleicht aufgrund der äh Verwandtschaft im im zugrunde liegenden Quellkrot relativ schnell sagen konnte, okay, kenne ich, habe ich schon mal gesehen
will ich nicht ausschließen.
Auch die Deutschen gewesen sein.
Vielleicht war's sogar ich. Da oder unsere russischen Freunde.
Und unsere chinesischen.
Also nichts Genaues weiß man äh äh nicht. Mal gucken, wie dieser Cyberattacke noch so umgegangen wird. Äh klar sollte auf jeden Fall jedem sein, dass es so ein bisschen die Essenz
klare Aussagen sind hier einfach grundsätzlich schwierig, so einfach aus technischen Erwägungen und weil natürlich hier einfach das Hakenschlagen im Netz, das ist einfach
normal und einfach zu machen und deswegen gibt's da keine schnellen Antworten.
Umso wichtiger wär's übrigens eigentlich ähm dass man.
In einem solchen Fall so blöd das jetzt klingt, also wir beschweren uns ja einerseits über die mangelnde Informationspolitik, aber natürlich hast du äh in einem solchen Fall die die wichtige und seltene Gelegenheit ähm,
eben die die Software des Feindes zu analysieren, zu erkennen und auszukundschaften und natürlich ist es am elegantesten.
Wenn du den Angreifer so lange wie möglich in dem, in dem Glauben hältst, dass du den Angriff noch nicht bemerkt hast.
Also äh da da beißen sich eventuell natürlich auch öffentliches Interesse und
die forensische, die forensischen Möglichkeiten, die man da eventuell haben kann. Andererseits kann's natürlich genauso gut argumentieren
Trojaner raus, so wir, das ist hier kein äh Spiel, wir wir reden hier von von Parlamentariern, wir müssen sofort so schnell wie möglich alles da rausschaffen, alle Systeme desinfizieren
und gucken, dass wir unsere Bude wieder dicht kriegen. Interessant ist dann natürlich auch noch die Frage, wie die Infektion jemals stattgefunden hat, ne? Ähm,
Ich habe das ja, glaube ich, schon öfter gesagt, so,
Trojaner zu bauen ist jetzt keine kein Hexenwerk interessant ist oder der interessante Teil ist
der Infektionsweg, also man versteckt den Trojaner irgendwie in dem System, lässt den da irgendwie sich einbuddeln, das ist alles irgendwie äh Basiswissen,
was, was man irgendwie hinkriegt so. Ähm das Entscheidende ist das ganze Ding so zu bauen, dass bei der Infektion ähm.
Niemand merkt, dass das System gerade infiziert wurde. Ja, also du willst äh wenn der Trojaner einmal installiert ist, dann läuft er erstmal als legitimes Programm auf diesem System mit und,
keiner wird jetzt irgendwie großartig mehr, was merken, der Infektionsprozess selber ist aber natürlich schon spannender, weil du
eben eventuelle Virenscanner, eventuelle Radgestreet, Wächter irgendwie umgehen muss und ähm.
Das äh ist in der Regel der der schwierigere Teil.
Gut. Denke, dann können wir das jetzt auch äh abschließen. Da ist jetzt nicht so.
Nee, nee, der das Thema ist ja das Thema kommt ja noch, sorry, das Thema kommt ja.
Thema kommt noch, was.
Ja, ja. Also, sorry, wir sind da so ein bisschen abgeweicht, ne? Äh abgewichen, der ähm dieser Trojaner wird also jetzt forensisch analysiert und.
Die Bundesanwaltschaft ermittelt. Die Bundesanwaltschaft ermittelt und man ist teilweise echt erstaunt, wie schnell so eine Bundesanwaltschaft ermitteln kann,
Wenn man sich nämlich an die Strafanzeige der Internationalen Liga für die Menschenrechte, des Chaos, Computerclubs und der Digitalcourage aus dem,
Februar des letzten Jahres erinnert.
Ja, da muss ja noch geprüft werden, oder?
Wird noch geprüft, da gibt's bisher noch keine Ermittlungen, ja, da gibt's ja noch nicht mal irgendwie so eine Anfangsuntersuchung
Und aus diesem Grunde ähm haben wir jetzt die zwei Jahre Snowden äh genutzt
um nochmal daran zu erinnern, dass es da ja noch was gibt, was bei ihm eigentlich auf dem Schreibtisch liegen sollte und haben da nochmal ähm die Strafanzeige erneut erweitert
und zwar in Form eines das ist so ein spezieller äh so ein schöner Begriff.
Also wir haben den Schriftsatz erweitert, beziehungsweise die Anwälte haben den Schrittsatz erweitert und da gibt es irgendwie ein, ein schönes Wort für, dass ich aber leider nicht.
Nicht genau erkennen, dass irgendwie eine Antwort oder sowas. Auf jeden Fall wurde er daran erinnert.
Doch bitte mal äh jetzt Untersuchungen aufzunehmen. Und das Interessante oder ein Verfahren, ein Ermittlungsverfahren einzuleiten, was er bisher nicht getan hat. Und jetzt ist äh interessant ähm.
Der Grund, warum er das nicht getan hat bisher und warum er auch das noch nicht abgelehnt hat bisher ist, in dem Moment, wo er es ablehnt, äh öffnet sich für ähm.
Uns, der ähm der die der Rechtsweg. Und,
Deswegen hat er das einfach auffindet
und wird wahrscheinlich dann immer sagen, ja, ich habe hier noch so viele andere Sachen zu tun und irgendwie, das war die, die Belege, die ihr anbringt, sind ja irgendwie noch nicht so wirklich ausreichend, aber so wirklich einstellen kann ich's auch nicht. Also, der windet sich da
ähm insofern haben,
die beteiligten Organisationen, die ja nicht inzwischen nicht nur die drei sind, sondern auch noch weitere Organisationen, die sich hier angeschlossen haben und irgendwie, ich glaube, anderthalb oder zweitausend Individuen, die sich dieser Strafanzeige angeschlossen haben. Da wird also äh
weiter untersucht.
Ja, ist doch schön, dass da äh weiter untersucht wird. Die Frage ist, äh muss eine Staatsanwaltschaft nicht irgendwann auch mal reagieren? Sonst äh könnte doch auch gleich wieder so Verschleppungen äh et cetera geltend gemacht werden oder gilt das für die einfach nicht.
Das weiß ich nicht genau wie. Also ähm ich muss sagen, dass diese Sache.
Insgesamt in den Händen der der Anwälte dort liegt und die werden schon diese ganzen rechtlichen Bedingungen besser kennen als äh wir.
Naja gut, als ich meine Februar zwanzig vierzehn, das sind ja jetzt grade mal na ja, sechzehn Monate oder so.
Ja, ja, aber wenn man sich überlegt, dass da irgendwie, also interessant finde ich halt, sobald irgendwo in der Zeitung steht, die Russen haben Trojaner in, äh, da irgendwo reingeschirrt, da ist der sofort dabei mit irgendwelchen Ermittlungen, ne? Da lässt er nicht lange auf sich warten.
Während andere Sachen da eben offenbar nicht ganz so hoch auf seiner Priorität Liste stehen.
Wir werden auch äh werde auch regelmäßig so von internationaler Presse dann dazu gefragt, die immer sagen so, ja, was ist eigentlich aus eurer äh Strafanzeige da geworden? Und da muss man auch immer sagen so, ja, wie
Bis heute äh wissen wir da relativ wenig drüber. So ist das.
So ist das. Gut, jetzt aber weiter im Programm, oder?
Ja, äh haben wir sind wir vorbereitet für eine.
Versuche die Handzeichen zu machen.
Ach so, äh hat mir da nicht gerade noch einen, ach, das ist schon mal wieder ein Thema rausgeschmissen.
Rausgeschmissen, ja. Machen wir nicht.
Ähm nee, ich bin jetzt gerade nicht fit, der das äh vorbereitet, aber ich wollte eigentlich auch nur noch mal ganz dezent äh drauf hinweisen, nicht dass wir das nicht schon tausend Mal erwähnt hätten, aber irgendwie wird's ja jetzt langsam warm
und ähm,
Ja, äh wer von euch noch nicht äh geplant hat für das Chaos Communication Camp, sollte vielleicht mal für das Chaos Communication Camp äh planen, weil es ist ja bald.
Dreizehnter bis siebzehnter August im Ziegeleipark Mildenberg in der Nähe von Berlin.
Genau und wer auch noch nicht so ganz äh verstanden hat, was ähm das äh ist, ja, also es ist halt einfach, wie soll man denn das beschreiben.
Das einfach gelebter Wahnsinn mit Technik aufm aufm Acker. Also es äh oder? Kann man das kann man das so zusammenfassen?
Es hat ja nicht so sehr diesen diesen Charakter äh des Kongresses, der so,
zumindest früher so primär von dem Vortragsprogramm und von dem Inhaltlichen geleitet ist. So, ja.
Lebt sich eigentlich sehr viel mehr so die äh
die äh aus, wo man halt einfach Sachen mitbringt, selber seinen Space baut, sein sein sein eigene Neigung dort quasi,
zeigt und teilt und, und, und, und dann auch viel Zeit damit verbringen kann, herumzulaufen und sich anzuschauen, was die anderen alle so machen. Das findet natürlich jetzt in zunehmenden Maße auch auf dem,
also ich würde sagen, die Entwicklung, die der Kongress in den letzten Jahren genommen hat, die ist vor allem auch vom Camp beeinflusst.
Aber das also das Cap ist einfach nochmal um
um Massengeiler, also von der, von dem, was die Leute da anschleppen, weil man muss sich vorstellen, da sind halt dann irgendwie drei, viertausend äh Hacker aufm aufm Acker, die alle irgendwie anreisen in ihren in ihren Bezugsgruppen, ja?
Und dann irgendwie natürlich irgendwie eine Fahne in den Boden rammen und dann irgendwie mal alles aufbauen, was sie haben so. Was ich am
Also was ich immer faszinierend finde, sind so die die Österreicher, die da anreisen, ähm das Metalab vor allem, die dann damit irgendwie so einem Anhänger,
mit so einer Funkanlage draufstehen und erstmal irgendwie noch so ein so ein so ein Flock in den Boden rahmen, wo dann irgendwie so eine riesige Antenne drauf ist, die mir echt Sorgen macht und ähm
dann fragt man irgendwie so, ja ähm also es ist eigentlich meine meine Lieblingssituation beim Camp äh zweitausendelf und ich sagte so ähm.
Was ist äh was macht ihr hier mit dieser Antenne? Dann war die Antwort so ah wir,
Wir senden ein Signal auf den Mond. Es wird dort reflektiert und auf der anderen,
Hälfte der Erdkugel empfangen. Und dann sagst du so, aha, warum?
Und warum macht ihr das? Und dann guckt ihr dich nur so an, so verständnislos und sagte, also ich erkläre es dir nochmal,
Wir senden ein Signal zum Mond. Es wird dort reflektiert und auf der anderen Seite der Erdalbkugel empfangen und wir erhalten eine Antwort. So,
Das war eigentlich so der Grund, warum wir es tun. Also das fand ich das fand ich sehr geil. Und mein mein immer noch absolutes Highlight des ähm des Camps oder der Camps ist der äh Palatschinken Roboter.
Eine eine Maschine, die Palatschinken produziert
und äh also ewiger Pflegebedarf, ja also das Ding hat bis jetzt in seltensten Fällen äh reproduzierbare Ergebnisse geliefert. Es ist es muss immer irgendeine Schraube nachgestellt werden und die innige Pflege, die dieses Gerät erfährt
und die Qualität der ähm der Palatschinken, die es rauswirft äh ist äh beeindruckend und das gilt,
für das sind nur zwei Beispiele von wunderschönen Hackereien und Spielereien, die man da in den verschiedenen Zelten äh begutachten kann, da will natürlich keine
Gruppe sich lumpen lassen und das Ganze irgendwie aufm Acker im Zelt ist echt beeindruckend.
Ja, dann hört sich ja immer alles ganz genau neben, äh weiß ich gleich mal darauf hin, dass äh der gemeine äh der gemeine Österreicher normalerweise nicht durch einen Schweizer Tonfall äh auffällt, äh nur um,
äh Nachahmungskünste hier gleich mal äh zu relativieren. Und äh ich vermute auch mal, dass da in den letzten Impressionen tatsächlich noch von äh der Veranstaltung in
Holland stammen und nicht vom letzten äh.
Nein, das stimmt nicht. Diese große.
Camp gab's auch schon, die da stimmte Palatschinken.
Beim Metalapp, da habe ich habe also ich habe, war deshalb so interessiert an dieser Antenne, weil ich daneben gezeltet habe
und sicher gehen wollte, dass das da alles noch so safe ist und dass die einen ordentlichen Blitzableiter und so weiter haben. Nee, nee, äh da bin ich schon ein Firmen. Aber natürlich in Holland waren die auch und da haben sie mit der da haben sie nämlich auf die ISS geballert, mit ihrer nachfolgenden Antenne, die irgendwie dann da ähm flog die ISS über den Himmel und die Antenne auf dem Dach des Anhängers.
Einmal echt irre.
Das war wirklich großartig.
Dann äh sei natürlich noch darauf hingewiesen viel zu spät, dass an diesem Wochenende nämlich dem Wochenende vom vierten Sechsten, beginnend mit dem vierten Sechsten bis zum siebten Sechsten die Gulasch-Programmier-Nacht in,
Karlsruhe stattfindet, ausgerichtet von dem äh CCC Erfurt Enttropia. Auch diese eine sehr spannende äh und reizvolle Veranstaltung, die sich sicherlich auch noch über kurzfristige Besucher
freut.
Ja, das ist die Veranstaltung, die ich also mit einer Zuverlässigkeit verpasse, das ist wirklich alarmierend,
Also weil ich ich war, glaube ich, auf der ersten und habe und ich war irgendwann nochmal zwischendurch, also auf zwei GP-Ins habe ich's irgendwie geschafft, ja. Äh von.
Fünfzehn oder was? Oder nein, das ist nicht die Fünfzehnte, ist nicht die Fünfzehnte, oder? Tut mir das nicht an, die heißt jetzt fünfzehn, weil es zwanzig fünfzehn ist, ne?
Wann war die erste zwanzig zweitausendzwei war die erste, ja okay, alles klar, also gute Güte oder doch?
Mich ein bisschen durcheinander. Sind das fünfzehn?
Zweitausendzwei die erste war. Ja ja ja ja okay, wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall ähm geht da mal hin, dass es irgendwie äh sehr nett und ähm ich werd's in Zukunft auch weiterhin äh
probieren, aber irgendwie, ich bin immer nicht im Land oder bin immer irgendwo grade woanders und das ist äh ganz furchtbar.
Ja, dafür weisen wir jetzt darauf hin.
Dafür weisen wir darauf hin, dass wir leider die Goulasch-Programmier-Nacht äh hier aus der Ferne äh grüßen müssen.
Genau, diesmal gibt's Termine auch wieder mit dem Bümmen, aber das hatte ich jetzt irgendwie gerade nicht bereit.
Tja, das äh musst du verantworten, das musst du mit deinem Gewissen vereinbaren. Ich kann da nichts zu sagen. Das ist.
Kein Problem, ich äh ziehe mich nachher zurück und heule ein bisschen.
Ja. Gut, dann äh bleibt an dieser Stelle noch der ähm sehr herzliche Dank an den.
Patrick oder Patrick? Hm, der diese Sendung nachhaltig äh beeinflusst hat durch gute Laune. Und ähm.
Verabschiedung.
Die Verabschiedung, die steht jetzt an. Ich weiß nicht, wollten wir am Ende nicht noch irgendeine Epiloten noch auf irgendwas eingehen? Jetzt habe ich das schon wieder ganz vergessen. Irgendwas war.
Mit Computern oder so.
Irgendwas mitkommt
Putan, keine Ahnung. Die Sendung ist schon wieder viel zu lange. Äh wir wünschen euch auf jeden Fall äh auch weiterhin eine Menge äh Spaß, Kopf hoch, ruft eure SPD-Abgeordneten an, auch wenn's vielleicht nichts bringt, aber macht's einfach mal trotzdem. Dann lernt ihr die mal kennen und fragt ihr einfach mal, was das alles soll.
Und äh ja, ansonsten.
Nein, jetzt fällt's mir wieder ein, die, die, die, die ähm die, die, die, die Pläne zur Weltherrschaft, genau. Also ich ich bin ja nach wie vor an ähm,
Ideen interessiert, wie man das Logbuch Netzpolitik ähm in ähm Hörergruppen äh,
oder Bevölkerungsgruppen tragen könnte, die vielleicht bisher nicht äh,
das Logbuchnetz Politik hören. Und man könnte jetzt also ich kriege immer zum Beispiel Spam von Google, die sagen, mach mal Google Adwords ähm
Es gibt natürlich auch andere Verteilwege, andere Plattformen. Man könnte Apps bauen. Es gibt so viele Möglichkeiten, irgendwie einem einem Podcast zur,
vielleicht irgendwie in die Breite zu tragen. Die Frage ist, welche dieser Möglichkeiten auch am Ende irgendwie sinnvoll wäre. Und ich würde mich freuen, wenn ihr in den Kommentaren äh vielleicht,
Vorschläge machen könntet, was was ihr
euch als sinnvolle Maßnahme vorstellt, wie man das Lokbuch vielleicht noch ähm bereitstellen kann
verschönern kann besser bewerben kann. Vielleicht sollten wir 'ne Kooperation
mit der deutschen Bundeswehr eingehen, um bei denen auf dem Truppenradio zu laufen oder was weiß ich. Also es gibt ja verschiedene ähm Ideen oder Möglichkeiten,
ähm.
Verfällt auch äh leider auch ein paar Ideen, die die deutlich über äh packt das doch auf YouTube oder packt das doch auf Facebook äh hinausgehen.
Ja, ich habe jetzt extra, also du kennst ja, du kennst ja den Trick, ne, wenn du im Internet die Antwort auf eine Frage suchst, gebe die falsche Antwort. Die Frage zu stellen bringt dich nicht weiter. Du musst einfach die falsche Antwort geben, dann kommt auf jeden Fall jemand, der dir die Richtige gibt, ja.
Das ist ein guter Trick.
Und genau so ähm habe ich jetzt mal ein paar Optionen genannt, aber es werden also ähm ich fände das schön, da irgendwie noch so andere äh andere Wege zu finden oder ja.
Komme euch da da gute Ideen, die ihr dann auch direkt äh bereit seid, unentgeltlich äh umzusetzen. Ähm.
Natürlich unter einer sehr strengen Aufsicht von Tim,
und mir und harscher Kritik und viel Feedback und vielen Änderungswünschen, keine Ahnung, ich weiß nicht. Vielleicht kommen euch ja irgendwelche Ideen.
Hm. Gut, jetzt ist aber Schluss hier.
Hier mal äh Apparat äh zumachen und äh ja, wir bedanken uns fürs Zuhören, fürs Unterstützen, fürs äh auf die nächste Sendung, fiebern und wir hoffen, dass wir jetzt bis zur nächsten nicht mehr so viel Zeit verstreichen lassen. Stimmt.
Jo, tun wir, wären wir nicht nächste, nächste Sendung, nächste, nächste Woche, nächste Sendung.
Tschüss.
Ciao ciao.